[Music]
starwars the last Jedi delivers a
soaring blend of drama action and comedy
while also tying up a few loose ends
left in the wake of the force awakens
writer director Rian Johnson chapter
successfully and perhaps controversial
thrusts the franchise forward in the
number of meaningful ways and it does so
largely by answering a few lingering
questions along the way
warning major spoilers ahead who are
Ray's parents it seems that in the Star
Wars universe all our favorite
characters are related in some way Darth
Vader was Luke's father Leia is Luke's
sister han Solo and Leia were married
for a time and kylo Ren also known as
Ben solo is there angsty villainous son
so when Rey was introduced in the force
awakens questions regarding her true
lineage ran rampant after years of
speculating that Rey was somehow related
to Luke Skywalker or obi-wan Kenobi the
last Jedi put all the rumors to bed in
one of the film's most subversive plot
twists Rey faces a deep truth about her
parents identities her parents were just
a couple of heartless and nobodies who
sold her off as a child of course this
bombshell could just be a red herring
but in a series that has become notable
for secret familial ties the notion that
Ray could be special just because she is
makes for a delightful change of pace
can Leia use force powers during the
credits of the last Jedi in loving
memory of our princess Carrie Fisher
appears on the screen while that
heartfelt goodbye acknowledges fishers
untimely passing the last Jedi story
does not but it does give her some
awesome powers early on kylo Ren leads
an attack on Leia ship there's a moment
when Leia senses her son's presence but
while he's successfully disposed of his
father in the force awakens kylo finds
himself unable to fire on his mother
instead his minions do the dirty work
and Leia's body is thrown into space but
it turns out that Leia is as tapped into
the forest as a brother and unbelievable
as it seems she uses the force to
navigate through the crushing vacuum of
space and back to safety back on her
ship Leia falls into a deep coma which
he remains in for the majority of the
film why does Luke want the Jedi to end
the ending of the force awakens found
Rey finally facing Luke Skywalker the
legendary Jedi who've gone and
hiding while fans were expecting an
emotional meeting between the two things
don't go down as planned when Ray finds
him on the planet where the first Jedi
Temple was built Skywalker takes his old
lightsaber and tosses it off a cliff why
is he so disdainful of the Jedi
it seems that Skywalker took the blame
for kylo ren's turned to the dark side
this all stems from Luke's failure to
train Ben solo in the ways of the force
when solo was a student Luke came close
to murdering him in his sleep because he
was frightened by the deep well of
darkness he sensed in the boy Ben woke
up to find Luke staring down at him with
lightsaber in hand and responded with a
fiery rage Ben destroyed the Jedi School
many of its students and assumed he'd
ended Skywalker in the process following
these events Luke decides he wants the
Jedi to end because theirs was a legacy
of hubris and failure capped by Luke's
own epic film which turned Ben solo into
kylo Ren and helped fuel the rise of the
first order
the snoke's identity even matter when
the force awakens hit theaters
speculation ran rampant regarding
supreme leader snoke s-- real identity
appearing only as a giant ominous
hologram Snoke was presented as
essentially the trilogy's new emperor
his motivations for turning kylo Ren
into the next Darth Vader helped fuel
the burning question who is this guy as
frustrating as it may be the last Jedi
doesn't deliver any new revelations on
that front what the movie does do is
finally give us smoke in the flesh as he
dishes out pain to kylo Hux and even Rey
before a surprise twist puts kylo and
Rey on the same team destroying Snoke
and splashy guards when all said and
done
it seems smokes true identity is well
just Snoke while it's likely his
backstory will be explored elsewhere as
far as the sequel trilogy is concerned
it seems we've learned all we need to
know about kylo ren's former master
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Applause]
[Music]